[Music]
[Applause]
all right I had an interesting week last
week I was riding in a cab and I found
someone's phone which is a weird
experience to find someone else's phone
first thought immediately do I keep it
no it's a droid this guy's got it tough
enough I'm not gonna kick a man when
he's down now the [ __ ] was ringing when
I found it and it kind of threw me off I
didn't know what to do so I just picked
up the phone real quick who's like hey
if you want your cell phone I'm gonna
leave it at the front desk of the
Warwick hotel and then I dropped off the
phone
feeling like I had done a good deed but
I forget how creepily deep my voice is
so whoever made that call got two rings
in and then just heard if you want your
cell phone it'll be at the front desk of
the ruler go to front of hear from you
in the hour I'm gonna start sending
pieces first
I truly believe something it's weird to
me that in this country some people
treat their cellphones better than their
grandparents
it's mean I love my grandma she's
awesome she's 86 she bakes we play gin
rummy together she talks about death
with an ease that rattles my bones
it's creepy have you ever talked to a
really old person about death
it's just facts no emotions it's the
closest I've ever came to interviewing a
serial killer
grandma what happened to rose next door
she's gone did she move
you're never gonna find her did you did
you kill Rose Jim oh you sneaky Nana so
good a chick I find it weird that in
this country old people are treated so
poorly for the main reason that they're
not good with technology we have all
this brand-new technology in the last 12
years old people aren't good at it so we
think it's okay to just disrespect them
to their face so give another gmail
account grandma how do you not have a
gmail account I was born during the
Great Depression
I remember when straws were invented my
mana doesn't know how to turn on an iPad
Nana how can you not turn on an iPad hey
kid I used to bang a guy that killed
Nazis a good job of those Angry Birds
I think that was it I think that was the
greatest generation that's why they're
called that and then it slowly just gets
worse it worse trust the children once
being made now the 2014 model no thank
you
mostly because their parents are my
friends they shouldn't be breeding their
animals you know what it is though it
really is little kids now are like the
opposite of old people they're way too
good with technology while remaining
terrible socially to the point that I
feel like they're messing with us have
you seen a two-year-old on an iPad it's
disturbing how accurate they are there's
like and look at me like I don't believe
that I just watch you do a bank
transaction don't you Keyser söze me
just put the money in my overseas
account Dickey handed little liar you
know it really disturbs me the most
though the thought that that's the
generation that's gonna have to defend
us against China you feel safe you feel
safe knowing that an entire army in 20
years that's like I would storm the
beach but I have a shellfish allergy
thank you guys very much you America